yeah we gotta talk about that
[Music]
so around about
nine months ago or so the doctor who
episode the timeless children
dropped answering the question that had
been built up across
series 12 who or what
is the timeless child
the answer got a um
let's go with mixed uh reception
i personally hated it and not for the
reason that
a lot of other people hate it like look
there's many reasons
to hate the timeless children and there
are reasons to like it i've seen
arguments that i'm like i don't agree
but i do understand how you got there so
like
i don't like it if you like it that's
fine if you dislike it for a reason
other than me
that's fine but just to recap
my problem with the timeless child is
not
the fact that it messes with canon i
mean honestly doctor whose cannon is so
freaking loose and nebulous anyways i
i don't really care so much i think
honestly that's the benefit of the show
i think it's actually really hard to
break canon in a truly significant way
just because there's so much that is not
firmly established and
the show's better for it so i don't
really care about
the i'm not a lore hound i don't really
care about that
i don't even really hate it for the
whole idea of
pre-heart no doctors i don't like that
but i don't hate it either ultimately
that's the kind of thing where i'm like
uh okay it doesn't
really fundamentally change the nature
of the doctor especially given that by
every indication any
uh regenerations preheartenal have been
wiped from memory
so the doctors still are still allowed
to be
you know who they were at that time it's
not like hartnell is now
no longer the first doctor as far as he
was concerned at the time he was the
first so
like i can even get over that now the
reason i hated this
is because it makes the doctor too
damn important i've talked in other
videos
i really really really don't like the
doctor being super important
the doctor should be important to the
stories to the companions
the doctor should not be universally
important
the doctor shouldn't even really be
important to the time lords at most the
doctor should be a nuisance
the doctor should not be mythical or
fabled
among the time lords the doctor sure as
heck should not be
this massive mythical figure
across all of time and space and the
doctor
definitely shouldn't be the entire
reason that
time lords can even regenerate it makes
the doctor so important
and i hate that like i hate chosen one
narratives i
hate oh this person is the most
significant or the absolute
best at or whatever i like i hate that
it's not even that it's boring it's like
i just completely disengage from it
i love the doctor when the doctor is
just stumbling on
doing their thing and helps when they
see people in trouble
that to me is the doctor and like to be
fair this
instance and the whole thing with the
timeless child is far from the first
time that the show
mainly in new who has made the doctor
really important
they did it with the doctor's place in
the time war
he was the one who ended the whole thing
and wiped out both races he thought
turned out he didn't that the doctor
saved all of gallifrey
like okay the
banking on his uh reputation which he
did his tenant and he did
as smith and freaking
resurrected by people's faith in him
like he was jesus at the end of series
three i don't like
any of that and the timeless child is
the most egregious
example i can think of of making the
doctor the most important thing
and i do not like it i didn't like it
when it aired i
still don't like it now almost a year
later
i still hate this
i also don't think they should write con
it
this has more to do with my
philosophical
notions about when you should even be
employing retcons in the first place
than it does with how much i dislike
this specifically because
as i think i've illustrated i really
don't like this
i really really really really really
don't like it literally if the timeless
child had been
anyone else literally any other
entity in the freaking universe
i would not be upset the way i'm upset
about the fact that it's the doctor
so clearly i hate this why don't i want
it undone
well because i don't want the show to
spend any more time on it than is
absolutely necessary
that's one of the things about retcons
a retcon and again if you are
a real canon hound if you're really deep
into the lore and you want everything to
be consistent
you probably are going to be more in
favor of retcons than i am
because in that case a retcon cleans
things up
it makes some corrections it it smooths
things over it removes stuff that was
problematic me i don't care
i want new stories that's what i come to
any long-running medium for whether it
is comic books
whether it is a show like doctor who
whatever it may be
i want things to move forward by its
very nature
retconning is looking back even if it's
looking back to fix something
all you're doing as far as i'm concerned
is drawing more attention to it
now i expect that chris chibnall is
going to do
whatever it is he thinks he can do or
wants to do
with the whole idea of the timeless
child who knows what that'll be
maybe i'll even like it i'm not
expecting to
but hey who knows
but once that's done
i don't want to hear about the timeless
child again and
retconning it all that does is bring it
back
up it just brings up the pain
again and it robs us robs us of a chance
to just keep moving forward
in my mind there are different kinds of
things that get labeled as retcons there
are things that are
honestly just filling in holes with
information we didn't have and sometimes
those holes can recontextualize things
that's where things like oh this
person's actually related to this person
in some way kind of
thing ends up feeling at least to me
for me a proper retcon isn't just an
additional piece of
information it actively undoes something
it takes something that was here's a
thing that happened and
actively makes it no it is a completely
different thing now
so that covers you know your people
coming back from the dead who were
clearly
at the time presented as having died
um anything well you you would think
with time travel so quarter you would
think doctor would be
rife with retcons it really isn't really
only big finish seems to indulge much in
retconning and even that
tends to usually be more explaining
things that don't quite fit into the
lore as we understand them
things like the whole is the doctor half
human
question from the uh the tv movie that
paul mcgann was in
but big finish is a good medium to do
that and because it's a medium that is
only indulged in by the hardcore fans
the kind of people who
care about that for the tv show
to eat up time and
rather than doing new stories and giving
us new adventures
to waste an episode two episodes god
a series who knows undoing something
that someone else did
what a waste of time just move forward
for me nine times out of ten the better
solution than a retcon
is just to not talk about the thing you
don't want to deal with
just don't bring it up ignore it now
is that to say that there's never a time
to use a retcon no there are in my mind
the reason to use a retcon
and i'm not going to cite specific
examples i'm just going to give you my
broad philosophical thought
the reason to retcon something that i
will accept
is if the existence of the thing that
you need to undo
has pigeonholed your storytelling
ability
and exactly how that looks is gonna vary
a lot from show to show
story to story medium to medium but if
there is something that is in place that
is canon
that is severely crippling your ability
to tell stories in the way you
want to maybe a retcon is necessary even
then i would think most of the time it's
probably
not so like for example there was a
period of time
on doctor who where they felt the sonic
screwdrive was
was solving too many problems so they
just got rid of the sonic screwdriver
they didn't retcon it that the sonic
screwdriver couldn't do a bunch of stuff
we'd already seen it doing i just got
rid of the darn thing
or with the regeneration limit
so in the time of the doctor
matt smith is in his final regeneration
it counts he accounts for all the
regenerations
he is going to die and it's going to be
final
because 13 lives
has been canon inductor for a long time
and one way to fix that in theory would
have been to retcon it to no
actually it isn't that but that's so
embedded in so much of doctor who
no they just gave him a whole new
regeneration cycle
most of the time it is better to either
ignore it
or to add something that counteracts it
rather than
wasting the time to do a convoluted
story to remove
something with retcons theoretically you
put the cat back in the bag
but honestly it's way more work than
it's worth
i don't know what is going to do with
the timeless child
i don't have a lot of hope for it
because i hate it on the conceptual
level
but he's going to do whatever he's going
to do and then
after he's done with it whatever
showrunner comes after
just ignore it or honestly if
chippenhall stays on
once he's done his main story that he
wants to do with this if he does more
series after that
fine i hope he doesn't keep bringing it
up
get whatever it is you thought you were
you needed to do this in order to get
and then let's all just move on with our
lives
retconning is picking out an old wound i
would rather let the damn thing heal
over
so there's my rambly thoughts on why as
much as i hate the timeless child i
don't want a retconned
what are your thoughts on this whatever
they are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it usual stuff
to do you know what it is
like share subscribe i have a patreon
and you can go there to support me keep
this whole thing going this is in fact
my living and if you've ever wondered
how i'm able to ramble my way through
these well
caffeine certainly helps so maybe
consider checking out this video's
sponsor
zest tea available in canned sparkling
teas bag teas loose teas and
cbd products more caffeine than a cup of
coffee
helps your mouth keep up with your brain
maybe i don't know did anything that i
say make sense
who knows in any case you use the coupon
code nathaniel at checkout to get free
shipping
on your order so give that a shot check
my
stuff out comments all those things that
i mentioned go for it or
don't you don't have to
because end of the day you're the
council i just run the meetings and
until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
bye